phil est partout dans le monde on attend
le vaccin qui mettra fin à la crise
sanitaire
c'est important de développer des
solutions à travers le monde a pour
trouver ce vaccin on sait pas à qui va
découvrir dans cette course au vaccin
certains sont accusés de ne pas suivre
les règles
le canada les états unis et le royaume
unis soupçonnent le groupe de pirates a
pété 29 d'avoir infiltré des réseaux
informatiques dans leurs centres de
recherche
nous croyons que les services de
renseignement russes ont cherché par le
biais de cyber-attaques a miné les
efforts de ces trois pays déclare le
ministre des affaires étrangères
britannique
nous sommes au courant de ses activités
dit la porte parole de la maison blanche
les trois pays estiment que le groupe de
pirates pourrait avoir agi dans le but
de dérober les renseignements sur un
vaccin contre la copie de 19 la russie
se défend et dit qu'elle n'a rien à voir
avec ces possibles cyberattaques
le ministre canadien de la sécurité
publique dit que la situation est
inquiétante mais rappelle que la russie
n'est peut-être pas la seule à
commanditer des cyberattaques
le centre de sécurité des
télécommunications ne dit pas assez des
pirates ont réussi à voler des
renseignements au canada si tel est le
cas les pertes peuvent être importantes
pour les chercheurs chaque phase
clinique peut coûter 15 millions de
dollars se veut dire que tout cet argent
qui a mis le produit à l'état ou ccp
redoux et jean doit commencer
il s'agit d'un avertissement pour les
organismes de recherche ou pays selon
cet expert
sécurisez vos pratiques informatiques
donc appliquer les meilleures ce
berrichon peu afin de prévenir le pire
parce que le 11 bon je crois contre
l'horloge le premier ministre trudeau
crois qu'il faut poursuivre les efforts
en vue de trouver un vaccin malgré les
risques
nous allons toujours cherché à trouver
le juste équilibre entre la protection
de la propriété intellectuelle et la
participation dans le visible des
initiatives qui pourront directement
bénéficié le canada et le monde
le centre de la sécurité et des
télécommunications mène une enquête sur
des possibles menaces horizon
informatique des centres de recherche
depuis mai dernier
l'agencé estime qu'avec la pandémie le
risque d'être la cible de cyberattaques
reste élevé pour les organismes du pays
et le restera tant que vaccin ne sera
pas disponible ici julian lapointe radio
canada ottawa